so so extraordinary to be in the company
of my fellow nominees such powerful
filmmakers who have inspired me and I
have admired for some of whom for
decades and I would not be standing here
if it wasn't for Mark Bowl who risked
his life for the words on the page
and
wrote Such a courageous screenplay that
I was fortunate enough to have an
extraordinary cast bring that screenplay
to life in Jeremy Renner Anthony Mackey
and Brian Garrity
and the people of Jordan who were such a
so hospitable to us when we were
shooting and I just like to dedicate
this to the women and men
in the military who risks their lives on
a daily basis in Iraq
and Afghanistan and around the world and
may they come home safe thank you